LegalEagle is coming in loud and clear.
Thanks to Ting Mobile.
The president has been
diagnosed with COVID-19
and has been flown to
Walter Reed Medical Center.
His condition may be worsening.
This has huge implications
for not just the way
that the government is run
but also the 2020 election.
Now we all know that president Trump
mocked Hillary Clinton's pneumonia-
- She's supposed to fight
all of these different things
and she can't make it 15 feet to her car.
Give me a break.
- Made fun of Biden for
allegedly hiding from
the Coronavirus in his basement.
- Joe Biden is sleeping
or whatever he's doing
in his basement, he doesn't
seem to come out a lot.
- And made fun of Biden
for wearing a mask.
- Did you ever see a man that
likes a mask as much as him?
- And made fun of Biden
wearing a mask again.
- I don't wear a mask like him.
Every time you see him, he's got a mask.
He could be speaking
200 feet away from you
and he shows up with the
biggest mask I've ever seen.
- So let me acknowledge
the elephant in the room.
There may be some shouting
parade today from people
who are gleeful about this development.
I'm not one of those people.
COVID-19 is a serious apolitical
virus that isn't selective
about who it infects.
And I wouldn't wish it on anyone.
Many people who work in the
White House or Congress,
or attended fundraisers or
debates with Trump's staff.
Were also exposed and we should
hope that they all recover
with no complications.
However, this is truly unprecedented
for many different reasons.
First of all, the major
presidential candidates
both are over the age of 70
Joe Biden and Donald Trump
are both in the high risk
category for health complications
from COVID-19.
And it would be irresponsible
not to consider what happens,
not only to the campaigns, but
also the country as a whole,
if either of them dies
or becomes incapacitated.
Especially since president
Trump was diagnosed
with Coronavirus just 33
days before the election.
How will American democracy handle
this earth shattering event?
What if the president is incapacitated
or worse before the election?
And what happens between the election
and the Electoral College?
(trumpet blares)
Hey LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer
and a doctor.
The president has Coronavirus
and all four candidates
for president and vice president
are mixing and mingling
with the American people
during a pandemic.
How panicked should we be
about something happening
to one of them?
Well, we have to start
with the 25th Amendment,
the U.S Constitution,
original plan for what happens
in the event of a presidential disability
or inability to work, was
for the vice president
to take over.
This seems simple enough,
but Article 2, Section 1
Clause 6, doesn't exactly
explain how to decide
when a president is disabled or unable
to perform the duties of the office.
Congress passed laws to
clarify the procedure
but nothing was formalized
until the 25th Amendment
was ratified in 1967.
So let's talk about Section 3.
Section 3 of the 25th Amendment
provides the president
with the authority to
declare him or herself
unable to discharge the powers
and duties of the office.
If the president makes a declaration,
this officially transfers
authority of the office
to the vice president who exercises it
as the acting president,
until the president reclaims
this authority by declaring
the disability to be ended.
This could apply if the
president was having surgery.
For example.
The key aspect of Section
3 is that the president
has discretion over when it
applies and when it ends.
This has happened a couple times before.
Ronald Reagan sent a letter
suggesting that he was invoking
Section 3 when he underwent
surgery for a polyp.
George H. W. Bush was the acting president
for about eight hours after
which Reagan resumed duties.
When George W. Bush was
president, he formally invoked
Section 3 twice when he was anesthetized
for routine medical procedures.
As vice president, Dick Cheney
took over on both occasions.
So hypothetically let's say
president Trump declares
that he will be unable
to perform the duties
of his office during his
Coronavirus quarantine.
We know Mike Pence would
be acting president.
But there's one additional
wrinkle to consider.
Most scholars believe that
he would not be allowed
to continue in his role as
president of the senate.
According to the constitution,
"The Senate shall choose
"their other Officers, and
also a President pro tempore,
"in the absence of the Vice President,
"or when he shall exercise
the Office of President
"of the United States."
Under such a scenario,
the president pro tempore
would exercise the powers
and duties as the president
of the Senate for the
duration of disability.
The vice president would
resume both the title
and duties of president of
the Senate, once the president
declared his disability over.
Which brings us to Section
4 of the 25th Amendment,
which is far more complicated.
You've probably seen RESISTANCE Twitter
kicking around the idea
that the president's cabinet
invoking the 25th amendment,
because they allege
Trump is in the mental decline.
There is in fact a process for that
but it's never happened
and it's highly political
and unlikely to happen.
Section 4 provides for instances
of Contingent Presidential Disability.
This means that there may be
situations where a president
is unable to discharge
the duties of office,
but is unwilling or unable to declare
the disability under Section 3.
So if the president was suddenly taken ill
or put on a ventilator or
had an emergency surgery
or went into a coma, then
the 25th Amendment applies
because the president
wouldn't have the ability
to make that determination for themselves.
However, the authors of
the Amendment also wanted
to cover scenarios where the
president thinks he or she
is totally fine, but the
vice president and a majority
of the cabinet think that
he or she is not fine.
Remember America is the country
that was created in part
because colonists didn't want
to be ruled by King George
the Third, who was said to
be suffering from madness.
So if the president is
unwilling to declare themselves
incapacitated, then the
cabinet and vice president
may act under these
circumstances, this section
authorize the vice president
and the majority of either
the cabinet or any other
body established by law,
acting jointly, to declare
the president to be disabled.
The vice president would need
the concurrence of at least
eight of the 15 Cabinet Officers
to activate the Declaration
of Presidential Disability.
Now, once they notify
the president pro tempore
and the speaker,
the vice president immediately
assumes the powers and duties
of the office as acting president.
Now, the drafters of the
Amendment were well aware
that this opened up the
possibility of a president
being removed solely
for political reasons.
Therefore, the amendment gives
the president a way back in.
"If the President in a time
of his choice transmits
"a written message to the
president pro tempore and
"the Speaker that no disability exists,
"he or she resumes office."
This sets up a political showdown
because the vice president
and majority of the cabinet
have four days to contest
this finding, if they think
the president isn't capable
of serving.
And then Congress decides.
If a two thirds vote of
both Houses believe that
the president is unable to
discharge the duties of office.
The vice-president continues
as acting president
until the disability is resolved.
If a two thirds margin is
not obtained, or if Congress
is in session, but at
the time does not vote
on the question within 21 days
of receiving the declaration.
Then the president resumes the
powers and duties of office.
And similarly, if Congress
is not in session at the time
and assembles but doesn't
vote within 21 days
then the president resumes
the powers and duties
of the office.
Like I said, "This is complicated."
And Section 4 has not been
activated since the Amendment
was ratified in 1967.
But there are two events
during Reagan's presidency
where it arguably should
have been invoked.
On March 30th, 1981,
president Reagan was shot
and seriously wounded while
leaving a speaking engagement
in Washington.
Actually just down the street
at the Hilton on Connecticut.
He had an emergency surgery
and he was under anesthesia.
His aides debated whether
or not to invoke Section 4.
They were notified that a
full recovery was expected
and decided no further
action needed to be taken.
When president Reagan was
shot, Al Haig his Secretary
of state made the big
mistake of telling the press,
that he was in control while the president
was in surgery.
(indistinct chatter)
- As of now, I am in control
here in the White House,
pending return of the vice president.
And I'm in close touch with him.
If something came up, I will
check with him, of course.
- This was considered a faux
pas demonstrating ignorance
of the constitution by
a high ranking official
which made the government
look particularly bad.
And although people
remember Al Haig's comment,
few people are even
aware that the other side
of Section 4 was also in
play during his presidency.
Reagan's mental status was
also questioned by staff
when he was in office.
In 1987, former senator Howard
Baker, president Reagan's
newly appointed chief of
staff, reportedly received
a memorandum from an aide
that claimed the president,
"Was inattentive and inept."
The memorandum went on
to urge Baker to consider
the possibility of Section
4 of the 25th Amendment
might be applied.
Baker concluded, "The president
was attentive and alert."
And at a March 2nd meeting
dismissed the report.
Five years after president
Reagan left the presidency,
he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's.
And we don't know definitively
whether he suffered
from the disease while he was in office.
But what happens to the presidency
in the line of succession
is pretty simple in
comparison to what happens
if a candidate dies before the election.
And that is the big question
on many people's minds right now.
We don't have a Federal law that specifies
what happens if a candidate
for president dies
before the election.
In the absence of a Federal law saying,
"If a candidate dies, we do X, Y, and Z."
We have to look to several
places to determine what happens.
We look at the rules of
the political parties,
State law and cases, which are similar.
But I warn you that this is
largely uncharted territory
because we've never had a
presidential candidate die right
before an election in the modern era.
And we don't have any Supreme
court cases directly on point.
So let's first examine
what the political parties
have to say about this issue.
The Democratic National
Committee has a clear rule
for the situation.
The 447 members of the
DNC would meet and choose
their new nominee.
The DNC chair currently Tom
Perez is required to consult
with the Democratic leadership
in Congress and with the
Democratic Governors Association.
After the consultation,
the chair provides a report
to the DNC members who
then make the choice.
Presumably in this case,
they would pick Kamala Harris
if Joe Biden were incapacitated or other.
But they're not required to do so.
The Republican National
Committee has similar rules.
The RNC has 168 members,
three from each state
plus three from six territories.
The members would revolt
in a similar manner
as they did at the convention.
If those three members of a
state disagree with each other,
then they each get to cast
one third of the votes
of that state.
And again, they might pick
Mike Pence in this situation,
but they're not obligated to put him
at the top of the ticket.
As an example, consider
the 1972 general election
when the Democratic Party filled a vacancy
because vice presidential
nominee, Senator Thomas Eagleton
resigned at the end of July.
The Democratic National
Committee met on August 8th
to nominate R. Sargent Shriver
as the new vice presidential candidate.
So, so far so good, right?
I mean, the parties would
just decide who they wanted
and the voters would go vote.
Well, actually, no.
It's way more complicated than that.
The parties would still
need to replace the name
of their dead or incapacitated candidate
on each state's ballot with
that of the new candidate.
The constitution gives the
states the right to set the time,
place and manner over federal elections.
This gives states the power
to say how a candidate
gets put on the state ballot.
The courts have confirmed that
the states have a compelling
interest in finalizing the ballot
and establishing deadlines.
So far courts have been reluctant
to find any problem with
how the states finalize their ballots.
The states have considerations
such as timely handling
of absentee ballot, military
ballots, vote tabulation,
and they're allowed to
administratively run elections
without federal interference.
This is why states have
deadlines for when the parties
must certify their
candidates for the ballot.
And here, this is a huge
issue because most ballot
access deadlines have already passed,
because they were in August and September.
Only a few states have
deadlines in October.
California, New Hampshire,
Rhode Island and Wisconsin.
And a real problem arises
when the candidate dies
in October or November
which is too late to get
on the ballot, but right
before the election.
What happens to the vote
for the deceased candidate?
Well, we know the answer
when it comes to electing
a member of Congress and
it's potentially instructive
for a presidential candidate.
There are two main ways of handling this.
There's the American Rule
and the British Rule.
The constitution says, "The
House and the Senate each
"shall be the judge of the elections,
"returns and qualifications
of its own members."
So Congress gets to decide what happens
to a dead Congress person's vote.
Congress has always
followed the American Rule,
which says, "That the votes
given to the dead candidate
"are not void."
Those votes are considered
valid and if the dead person
receives the most votes,
this creates a vacancy
in the office.
That vacancy will be filled
according to the constitution.
And vacancies in the
Senate are filled in accord
with the 17th Amendment,
which permits governors
to temporarily appoint
someone to the Senate seat.
And here's an example how
that works in the real world,
Missouri governor, Mel Carnahan
won election to the Senate
in Missouri in 2000, 38
days after he and his son
died in a plane crash.
Under Missouri Election law,
the names of deceased
candidates remain on the ballot
if they die so close to the
election of the filing deadline
or the time for political
parties to substitute
a candidate has passed.
And Missouri law expressly
follows the American Rule,
which means that Carnahan's
death and the subsequent
victory created a vacancy.
Carnahan's death created two vacancies.
One in the Senate and also
one as Missouri Governor.
Roger Wilson, ascended
to the acting governor
upon Carnahan's death
and he announced that
he would appoint Jean Carnahan, Mel's wife
to the Senate seat.
House vacancies are also
handled according to State law,
but governors must provide
for a special election
rather than appointing
someone on an interim basis.
And this is what happened
when two Democratic members
of the House, Hale Boggs of Louisiana
and Nick Begich of Alaska were
killed on October 16th, 1972.
Under Louisiana and Alaska
law, it was too late
to replace them on the ballot.
Both deceased candidates won
their races and their seats
were eventually filled
by a special election.
But not everyone likes the
rule that dead candidates
can win elections.
The Minority Rule known
as the British Rule
would give the election to
the next highest vote getter.
This means that the
person who finished second
would be seated in the House or Senate.
This rule has not been followed
by either House of Congress.
And some argue that the
election of a dead person
should be considered a
nullity and we should just
have a new election to
fill the seat regardless.
The argument for the British
Rule is that the Senate
and House have a right to
judge the qualifications
of its members, and a person who is dead
can't be properly qualified.
Therefore the election
should at least be a nullity.
Congress has been reluctant
to adopt this British Rule
because it invalidates
the will of the people
in a popular election.
And it would arguably conflict
with a lot of State laws
which follow the American
Rule with their own precedent
for handling vacancies.
But this still doesn't tell
us precisely what would happen
if a presidential candidate
died in a Federal Presidential
election, when it was too late for them
to be replaced on the
ballots for all 50 States.
Moreover, the death of
a presidential candidate
does not create a vacancy.
So we need to look at how
presidents are elected.
So the question is what happens
if a presidential candidate
dies right before the election?
When voters cast their
votes on November 3rd,
they're not actually casting
votes for a specific person.
Instead they're casting
votes for a slate of electors
who will be sent to the Electoral College.
That makes the presidential
election different
from a Senate or House election.
And we can argue until the cows come home
about whether the Electoral
College is a good thing
or a bad thing?
But it's the system that we have.
So now let's assume
that the president dies
two days before the election.
There's not a time for the courts
to resolve the ballot access problem.
The election is happening
with his name on the ballot
in some states and Mike Pence's
name on the ballot in states
that allow him for a substitution.
And the first thing to know is
that if the president passes
away under the 25th Amendment,
then the vice president
becomes president no matter
what, because the rules
of succession established
by the constitution.
And if Biden won the
election, then there's
not really a problem.
Biden would be sworn in, in 2021.
And Pence would be president until then.
But what if Joe Biden dies
and then subsequently wins?
Does Kamala Harris become president?
And what if the combined
Trump's Pence ticket
receive 270 electoral votes, meaning that
the ticket won the election?
Does Trump get to be
sworn in for a new term?
Well, the answer lies with
the Electoral College.
So each state's electoral votes usually go
to the winner of the state's popular vote.
Some states allow electors to
vote for anyone they choose.
About 30 States require
the electorates to be bound
by the state's popular vote.
14 of the 30 States have laws mandating
that the electoral vote be canceled
if the person goes rogue.
This is called being,
"A faithless elector."
However, some States
simply penalize the elector
with a fine or short jail term.
But their vote can still
be cast for someone
other than the popular vote winner.
Few states actually have laws
specifying what electors do
if a candidate dies before
the Electoral College meets.
Indiana law says that, "Electors
should switch their votes
"to the political parties
replacement candidate."
So if a deceased candidate
Trump wins under Indiana law,
the electoral votes would go to whomever
the Republican party replaces him with
which may be Mike Pence, but
it could be somebody else.
In contrast, Michigan
law requires electors
to vote for the winning candidates
who appear on the ballot.
Presumably this means that they must vote
for the vice presidential
candidate on the ballot.
The electors may simply cast
their votes for the person
the winning political party has put up
as the replacement candidate.
Or an elector could believe
that they should cast
their vote for the dead
candidate because the state law
commands it or for any other reason.
An elector could do that even
though there is precedent
for Congress disallowing the
vote for a deceased candidate.
But what the state parties
and electors have to do
in this event is largely
governed by State law.
And as usual LawFare
has done the hard work
and taken on the herculean
effort of compiling
all of the law of the
states that are likely
to be in play here.
So if you're curious about
what the various State laws
mandate during a vacancy,
definitely check out LawFare.
In the 1872 election,
Congress decided not to count
three electoral votes for
presidential candidate
Horace Greeley, who had died
after the November election
but before the meeting
of the Electoral College.
Would Congress follow that precedent?
It's impossible to say.
If one party controlled
both Houses of Congress,
then it'd be easier for them to invalidate
the electoral votes of
the deceased candidate.
But the Electoral College does
not vote until December 14th
of this year, over a
month after the election.
If a candidate dies between the election
and the Electoral College voting,
the process is the same
that I talked about before.
The party seeks a replacement candidate
and the party would probably
expect their electors
to still vote for their new
candidate, but they're not
necessarily required to do so.
It depends on the State
law and they could vote
for another member of their
party or even a third party
candidate if they wanted to.
And then of course it
gets even more complicated
if no candidate can be certified to have
270 Electoral College votes
under the 12th Amendment.
Which we'll talk about in just a second.
So then there's the question
of what if a president-elect
dies after the Electoral College meets,
but before being inaugurated?
Congress will count the
Electoral college votes
on January 6, 2021.
They must then certify that vote.
And if a winning candidate
were to die in between
December 15th, after
the electors have voted
but before January 6th, things
start to get pretty messy.
There isn't a Federal
law that says whether
the electoral votes of
the deceased candidate
also count for the vice president.
The constitution's 20th Amendment
says, "The vice president
"elect becomes president
if the president elect
"dies before inauguration day."
But it also provides
that, "If the president
"has not qualified by January 20th,
"then the vice president elect
serves as acting president
"until a president qualifies."
The vice president elect who
is subsequently inaugurated
as president would then
nominate a vice president
under provisions in Section
2 of the 25th Amendment.
But that might not actually
resolve the problem here.
Does a candidate formally
become the president elect
after winning the Electoral College vote?
Or only after Congress certifies the vote?
This is a question that
has remained unanswered.
However, in the 1932 House
Committee Report accompanying
the 20th Amendment, it actually
explains that the authors
of the Amendment felt that
the counting of the votes
does not matter when
determining if a person
is president elect.
"It will be noted that the
committee uses the term
"President elect" in its
generally accepted sense
"as meaning the person who
has received the majority
"of electoral votes, or the
person who has been chosen
"by the House of Representatives
in the event that
"the election is thrown into the House.
"It is immaterial whether or not the votes
"have been counted, for the person becomes
"the President elect as
soon as the votes are cast."
This still isn't the clean
resolution that we were
probably hoping for in a
crazy hypothetical like this.
If Congress says it
cannot certify the count
for a dead candidate, for whatever reason
the Congress chooses.
Then the House of Representatives
picks the president
according to the 12th Amendment.
Under the 12th Amendment, if
no can candidate for president
receives a majority of the
Electoral College votes
then the House gets to decide.
And the House must choose from
the top three vote getters.
But this means that in a two horse race,
such as what we have this
year, then effectively
the living candidate would
then be become president.
But as you can imagine this
whole process would be insanely
political and basically chaos.
And it's not entirely clear,
but if the president elect
were to die after Congress has certified
the Electoral College vote on January 6th,
then the most likely scenario is that
the rules of succession would apply.
Meaning the vice president elect
would then become president.
But this whole situation
sounds like a recipe
for absolute chaos.
And I think I speak for most
Americans when I say that,
"Hopefully this is a normal
election between two healthy
"individuals and the winner
wins fair and square."
But at the end of the day,
if things do go pear shaped,
it's basically a matter of State law.
But those laws only come into
play if the election is close.
So let's make this election a blow out
and avoid another Bush versus Gore.
So call your friends and
family and tell them to vote
absentee or in person if they can.
And the best way to make that
call is with Ting Mobile.
Ting provides great LTE, 5G coverage
because it partners with
the biggest carrier.
So you get the benefit
of three massive networks
because Ting Mobile is a
different kind of mobile provider.
With Ting you only pay
for your actual data
and services that you use
at the end of the month.
And because you're only paying
for what you actually use
Ting customers pay on average
is 23 Dollars per month
from one device.
And with Ting, you can
use almost any cell phone
including the newest iPhones
and Google Pixel phones.
And you can use the same phone number
you're using right now.
There's no contract, overage fees
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair price
for the talk, text and data
that you use up every month.
And Ting has award-winning
customer service
because they don't have any
brick and mortar stores.
Not that any of us are
going to brick and mortar
stores these days.
They pour all of their
resources into their phones
and online support.
And if you have any issues,
you can give them a call
and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being.
With Ting, especially if you're
around WiFi all the time.
Which of course, most of
us are since a lot of us
are working from home.
You'll end up paying
way less than you do now
because you're not actually
using cells service
you're using the WiFi coverage.
Of course, some people should
pay 200 dollars a month
for unlimited data if they're
nowhere near their homes.
But if you're surrounded
by WiFi all day long.
Then you might be paying
hundreds of dollars more
for your cell phone,
completely unnecessarily.
And Ting gives you the option
to pay only for what you use.
So if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
And LegalEagles will
get a 25 dollar credit
by going to LegalEagle.Ting.com.
And that could cover your
entire first month of service.
And since there are no
contracts, you can try it
for a month no strings attached.
Again, all you have to
do is click on the link
in the description or go
to LegalEagle.Ting.com
and get a 25 dollar credit
for whatever service you want.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist
over here with my coverage
of all of the crazy
things that are happening
right before the election,
because it's 2020
and the law is crazy.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.